hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear memories okay
we are in the morgue and I thought by
hand [ __ ] wait ah able to get out of
here somehow
alright maybe I was wrong oh that's
right Oh too early for this okay ah
where these footprints come from who got
up from this bed ah what am i speak
Russian I'm a man of a man of the world
speak all these languages like crazy you
know yeah whatever alright what's up oh
wait first I'm gonna make sure that I
get through here first
forget what's in here oh wait nothing's
in here it's just oh yeah it's just open
another way out never mind never mind
oh I'm so silly come on now there we are
hook
huh
and if I remember correctly that board
breaks up yep totes remember that
roughly we didn't bowl afraid of
monsters game I doubt it no no they
wouldn't do that that's just silliness
the directors directors cut just for a
fray tomate art ah there are many I whoa
the roof is done a little differently
ah the first changes are evident ah
there we are
I know that there is a MOS catted about
up here pills over there bills here it's
over here I can't go bills here bill
pills here
okay can't jump on that for some strange
reason let me take a look at the map
ooh I wonder what those X's say info
maybe there's my atoms oopsie
oh yeah crap you're good dicks find
those items I gots to get the items
black dere's one and I already got that
Seng to fasten that one and I'll jump
off cuz why not oh yeah and you get up
got to jump to another way on the roof
here and then you can go right here
that's it ha ha ha ha
ah is it aha Hey
are you doing what are you doing get out
here there we go all right in here oh
yeah I'm the man I'm the best the best
you ever was well maybe not that good Oh
woman oh yeah
okay reception hall on each buses this
is where thee yep
man this is like a faithful recreation
dear yon neato I see a lot of the buns
every little electricity yep
oh boy strange tah-dah
door won't budge rocky boot cover won't
budge
[Music]
Ricky is locked
dammit I was hoping the strange key hmm
this is where things start to get a
little interesting ah I hate again well
time to plenty of em I like that I like
that lot that's right
whoo I should try that one first should
try this I've no I don't remember there
being a strange key before nope okay I'm
moving forward
ah of course there we go hello
here's anybody down here monster hookers
how can you feel like something's behind
a door I'm in touch with this door it
feels like there's something mind
all right here we go
my flashlight Oh
oh gosh I wore
okay there oh oh yeah holy crap that's a
new one garbage bag head oh man okay
my mother [ __ ] you ah got here oh now I
got a UH back out back
no that's not right ah screw it I'm
running I can't even see where I'm going
uh uh uh so dark
uh uh it wouldn't open before oh man oh
okay oh you think you get close to me
oh here we go
save
okay oh this is where it changes oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh I don't wanna i I
don't I don't I don't want to all right
here we go you [ __ ]
oh oh oh oh okay oh no no God how they
do that how many things you blurry done
farther nothing
hahaha
[Music]
oh hey daddy's okay
I am so much ma I need to stop playing
so much everyone starts oh oh I'm back
here
Oh Deckard appearance ah okay
[Music]
no more oh it's never over it's never
over the Bates Motel
are you kidding me
oh my god where am i where am i oh oh
you got to be kidding me Oh what do we
do
can't see anything
huh what happened how what did I do
what was that I didn't read that ha ha
ha
go back in here ok all right huh oh man
oh I did not why is everything in black
and white hey yeah yeah this key action
if it's get back yeah I think this is a
shower this is the one where the rear
eerie scene happened I'm pretty sure I'm
pretty sure
Oh what's going on yeah okay alright go
up to the hotel
awk wrap oh I know it's fun sound there
it's a car down there why
ah ha ha downing hey I got a doorknob if
you know what I mean no no not at all
what
okay what I somehow said it hit a safe
through that I whatever I bet the
doorknob is to this oh there's no
doorknob it's attached but but do you
know if it's the strangest thing
oh this will be good
the mod team oh yes go down to the
basement first great idea markiplier
best idea you've ever had
oh hi lady
Hey hi hi hi what are you doing got here
okay do it do it
ha no stairs
whoo you late it was that okay I'm just
I'm outta here
screw that I mean my goodness
ah this car may be the light of this car
by the light of this car I can give way
Hey yes awesome that's it guys
Hot Diggity man that was good I was fun
like the whole time loses I love that I
loved all the UM the varied things that
they had going on in this those that was
actually a lot of fun like some of those
scares oh my god
of course it gets cry fear so cry feels
really really good on the scares like
it's the game is built just for that and
they built it really well so thank you
to the cry for your team team
you
what what okay anyway anyway so
I think is it
you
huh I don't always say thank you for
making a team sigh Keller so I rank air
I didn't get it I did not get a good
rank when I played this the regular
progr campaign so
yeah I'll be okay with saying that I get
an F so oh no I'm ending scene I saw
ending F well I don't think in this
there were any other endings okay
all right Bailey thank you all so much
for watching and as always Oh see you
bye bye